welcome to this video playing a little
away from the Netherlands now we have a
Sicilian maybe I can do something else
let's let's play maybe I can try to play
this grand prix attack for once I don't
think I ever play it with white on a
video i had this is black sometimes i
recently got this move played against me
the proof to be surprisingly tricky and
i'm going to to try this out the idea
was that after e6 there was before and
interesting he's combating that maybe
i'll ever now maybe this has gained a
bit in strength now ACA three years a
useful move okay maybe I have a 2 now as
a good retreat square okay should I
retreat also every five maybe five or f5
mmm-hmm who knows many many
possibilities there's very often this f5
idea d3 and then later f5
your own light e7 looks very normal okay
is also fairly typical I can consider to
take yeah maybe take politics 92 should
be okay and Bishop takes looks like a
huge loss of time with Nigel you coming
maybe I can play nighty too and then
maybe even see 3d for just normal
central play but anyway the King needs
to be on h1 in any case uh yeah f5 has
gained somewhat in strength maybe I
should just do this five GF and then
Queen h5 something like that that's
dangerous come on let's do it it's also
f6 threatened so it is having some merit
of course EF there is some number of
moves actually be Bishop g5 maybe does
f6 if I recapture simply night takes
well that's not totally convincing okay
yeah I thought queen age five would be
good just activating and asking like
what's what's the next move really I can
continue with Bishop g5 for example to
increase the pressure
you cannot take e for and chan d 5mm md5
looks very risky even it takes f 59
f5f5f5 and then rookie one check comes
into consideration wow if i just take
this what exactly is coming after two
after Queen takes I don't know this also
Bishop g5 there's also night b5 many
many interesting rules I can also take
on on f5 I can just take on f5 actually
Knight takes rook at five EF Queen f7 is
made you cannot k cannot take on at five
then this is the easiest way while f7 s
just f7 is just a huge point of attack
ok I can take it six now instead of
recapturing isn't the strong yeah there
are g2 there's a to hanging wow wow wow
I just I just totally totally didn't see
that haha oh my god hmm I just totally
overlooked the bishop oh my god okay no
I this I must play even as Bishop before
you check
and Bishop have three wins the Queen as
well I just oh my god I absolutely
forgot that this rukon g8 I mean just
okay oh yeah there is still a threat on
f7 is this is this is this is still it's
not a silly game I don't know I can take
him he must take with the bishop wait
this isn't Bishop takes it does there
Jackie egg I can at least play on for a
moment be sure to check here maybe Luke
take rook Josiah and then move the rock
to hear maybe intending a discovery or
whatever down I'm who Queen down right
and this is probably a lot not at all
working that maybe maybe there is some
confusion value and this
yeah I'm certainly totally lost but what
exactly is the windfall like it is not
it's not so easy maybe at least
relatively speaking he wants to play
Bishop to f6 hmm if I play this
discovery I'd say it's a number of pins
really let's say Bishop g5 maybe Bishop
g5 I can go Kimmy son but slow
relatively best maybe night maybe book
okie one that won't get the routine to
play I Scott queen edge for him Queen
edge for is probably know this one I can
take here now time morning okay I need
to do this phone check
money I'm follow what materially just a
work wind down right okay come on there
is absolutely no attacking like resigned
oh man this is this on g2 where ever I
was totally oblivious to that really
totally oh man this means that i'm
already toast here EF wow yeah i just i
was just totally only looking at this
this stuff here and was too was Jack
knee was glad that this was on and
really really great i Luke Gianna this
is somewhat hidden this bishops III
stuff what what's a bit bit annoying is
that that that a normal move was just
excellent here Bishop g5 is great on a
queen eh7 is probably also good at this
Bishop f6 it seems okay but this is just
normal and and good in time it's not
clear what black is doing him we are
just just a huge attack like a son the
computer wants to wants to do something
like this John White has a has a very a
very good position here I mean this is
something else Bishop f4 is also
suggested by by the engine yeah their
various ways but I had that I mean here
if now I absolutely overlooked that g2
was hanging I mean here you can try
Bishop g5 to to continue at least not to
lose immediately um I mean it's close to
losing immediately of course this is
good for black but you can try at least
and he i'm just guessing the house just
check briefly that really is check it
really is no check check potential to to
do anything I know there's absolutely no
trick whatever yeah yeah I'm just just a
quick down yeah I must play a misplay
Bishop g5 yeah this uh he and this in
this moment yeah five is just just silly
okay thanks for watching